las vegas raiders played at allegiance  stadium on sunday they struggled though  to keep up with tom brady in the  buccaneers  final score from allegiant 45-20 tampa  bay  most of the raiders game day prep was  done via zoom last week  that's because one of the raiders tested  positive for the coronavirus last week  the entire offensive line quarantined  but later cleared  still it made things a bit challenging  las vegas takes on cleveland  next sunday and the eight sports now  team has you covered with all things  raiders you can catch the pregame show  lives on sunday morning starting at 8  o'clock  and you can be part of the show as well  send us pictures and videos of you  cheering on the raiders we want to see  raider nation picks pix  8newsnow.com